30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes
10 minute mindfulness ready to become
[Music]
get feel on the app store or google play
hi everyone it's joanna here today's
workout is going to be a 15 minute app
challenge
we want to work on the overall apps as
well as
your deep core muscles so let's get
a strong and toned meat section let's do
[Music]
it
[Music]
there will be a total of four circuits
each workout will be for 30 seconds long
with 15 seconds break in between okay so
before we start
let's do a little bit of warm up for the
core let's get into a plank position
and i want you to push your butt up into
a downward dog
just to stretch your entire body out and
also to start
to activate your core muscles so plank
and push into a downward facing dog
good few more
high plank and push
okay now what i want to do is cross over
and try to reach
for your ankles
cross tap back into a high plank
tap and back into a high plank
so throughout this movement i want you
to really be cautious of your abs
your core muscles and really suck and
tighten
your belly cross reach
and cross good give me a few more
high plank remember do not pike your
butt up
flat back cross and cross and now just
slowly lower your body down and get into
a cobra
and just stretch it out
good push into the floor and take a
moment to just
stretch it out all right
okay are we ready so the first
circuit is going to work on your overall
abs
upper lower as well as your obliques the
first exercise is going to be a big
movement okay so what i'm going to do is
lie
flat onto your mat it's going to be a
full sit up
with a russian twist so extend your arms
all the way
crunch up twist to the side down
up and twist so it's very important
that you twist your body and lift
your knees up good all the way crunch
extend and up
look the opposite side and breathe out
as you come up remember to slowly
lower your body back down so do not just
collapse
engage your core muscles lower yourself
back down
and crunch good remember to twist
tap the floor look the opposite
side very good okay
next is my favorite knee tucks all right
so place both palms
onto the floor with your fingers pointer
forward
straighten your legs all i want to do is
drive your knees in
extend it out in extend it out
and in good so crunch
and extend drive your knee close to
your chest there you go nice and
controlled
movement and remember to breathe up
as you crunch in good job
pace your breathing breathe out
breathe in out and in
and drop back down okay we want to
repeat
the entire circuit once more so remember
full sit up with a russian twist okay
arms
and feet both extended out ready crunch
in
tap back down crunch up
twist and down so tap
and look at the opposite side and
remember
control control the movement
one step at a time you should feel
your core burning
upper abs lower abs as well
as your obliques twist
give me one more twist good job
abs on fire okay now let's do
knee tucks okay so remember your
hands are just helping you to support
your upper body the work
should be coming from your core let's go
in
extend out breathe out good job
drive it in drive it in if this is too
tough
what you can do is tap rest for a while
crunch it in
extend crunch and extend
keep going
last 10 more seconds
crunch wake the abs up
let's tone up on our waistline very good
job
okay now let's move into
the second circuit for the second
circuit we want to work
on the deep core muscles we want to be
working on
planks okay small movements
but it's going to really hit the deep
core muscles and it's going to really
help you
with your posture as well as balance
so the first workout is going to be a
plank
knee tap so get into a plank position
straight line i want you to drop your
knees tap gently
and come back up so it's just a slight
tap
and back up and this is to create
the imbalance and for you to activate
your core
even more so small tap do not rest it's
just a small tab
up and down so gaze
gently onto the floor keep a neutral
position
tap up and up
good job okay all right
still in a plank position we want to
work
on rocking plank as well as plank hip
deep
okay so get into a plank position we
want to rock
forward and back twice and then dip your
hips
to the side twice okay
forward and back engage your car
and work on your obliques
as you dip your hips forward and back
and now deep remember do not
pike your butt up or
dip your hips okay maintain
a straight line all right good job take
a short break
if you want to you can get into a
child's pose
and slowly come back up are we ready for
plank knee taps
get into a plank position strong core
let's go tap
double knees tap good control up
there you go nice and controlled small
movement suck your belly in
engage your core and tap
remember to breathe okay do not hold
your breath it's not going to help
breathe
tap tap
and tap good job there you go keep going
and just drop your knees rest it
out all right one final
plank okay and we will move on to the
third
circuit let's keep our plank strong
let's go strong plank rock forward
and back twice hip dips
left and right good
forward and back and
deep to the side
and in a straight line do not
arch your lower back stay strong stay
with me
do not pike your butt up last few more
deep deep deep and
good job all right oh
do you feel the burn right here that's
what we want okay
all right the third circuit is going to
focus
on your oblique muscles so
the side muscles okay the one that we
want to work on to get that 11 line
so the first workout is going to be a
rainbow leg raise
imagine that there's a middle line
there's a line in the middle
what i'm going to do is cross over the
line
from left to right okay
so drive both legs to the left
and to the right as though you're
drawing
a rainbow left and right left
and right good and remember that
your arms are just supporting your upper
body
so the work should be on
your obliques good job keep going
and drop down okay now let's get into a
side
plank crunch all right so
stay on your elbows lift your hips
off the floor hands by your head
get into a crunch extend it out crunch
and extend it out if this is too
difficult what you can do
is just start on your knees extend
crunch
extend crunch and extend okay so choose
your
option what is most important is that
you don't
dip your hips lift it up and get your
lower your side
abs crunch extend
crunch and extend okay just working on
one side
and we will change on the second
round good job okay
rainbow leg raises love it or hit it
it's
really good for your obliques all right
so just support your upper body
bend your elbows slightly let's go from
left to the right
draw a nice big rainbow okay
nice i want to see a big
and colorful rainbow let's keep going
left and right left and right
feel the work on your waistline
extend extend your legs point your toes
to the side and good job okay now
let's work on the opposite side okay
so change the other way get into a side
plank
i'm gonna do the advanced version okay
so keep your leg straight
at the bottom extend your arms crunch it
in
extend it out crunch extend
and crunch so again i don't want you to
rush
through the movement i want you to find
your balance
try to drive your knees to your elbows
crunch it in extend point and crunch
don't rush keep it steady
and keep crunching and drop
back down okay
for the final circuit we want to end
with a little bit of
cardio abs exercises this is to really
get your heart rate up and to burn fat
from
the mid section okay so let's start
with mountain climbers and the second
workout will be plank
jacks so start in a high plank position
it's going to really drive your heart
rate up i want you to drive your knees
in towards your chest okay
knees in towards your chest and if you
want to
you can pick up the paste and get
into a run keep going
really push your pumps into the ground
and drive your knees in
and pace your breathing
strong core let's bring your heart rate
up
and just drop all right
oh i can feel my heart rate increasing
i'm breaking a sweat let's keep going
okay
the second abs cardio workout is going
to be a plank jacks
start in a high plank position jack in
and jack out okay
out and in again remember it is not this
okay
this is wrong flat back jack in
and jack out
strong arms keep the posture stable
raise the core and in and out
good job keep going a few more seconds
and rest it up alright so
you know the drill let's repeat those
two exercises again
take your breath let's go get into a
high plank
let's start with mountain climber okay
find your rhythm
either challenge yourself and get
into a running mountain climber
or take it a notch down and just drive
your knees
in towards your chest okay only 30
seconds guys
we are strong and this is your final
round so stay with me keep going
keep running run to the finish line
let's go
and drop oh my gosh all right
one final workout plank jacks
let's do this remember to push
your arms away from the floor okay let's
go
high plank jack in and out
flat back raise your core
20 seconds to the finish line
let's go work on
your core tone up on
the mid section keep going
five four three two
one oh my gosh well done
high five i know that
your abs is on fire right now
you're feeling tired but extremely
strong okay all right let's just take
this moment to just
bring our heart rate down breathe in
breathe out breathe in
and out okay guys very
very very well done i want you to
continue doing
this 15-minute app challenge for at
least
two to three times weekly for four
weeks okay in order to see results you
have to
be consistent in your workouts and
repeat the workouts
do combine this ab challenge with my
total body strength training
as well as total body heat workouts you
can also
end each workout session with this 15
minutes
app challenge okay so be sure to give
this video
lots of thumbs up do subscribe to my
channel
and don't forget to also check out a lot
more workout videos
workout plans meal plans as well as
nutritional tips to get you through
your fitness journey and i will see you
next time
all the best